اذا من البدايه بما اعلنه الكريم عن
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين زار ماريو
بول في اقليم دومباس للمره الاولى منذ
بدايه الحرب وتفقد عددا من المنشات
والمرافق في المدينه وقضى وصل الى مروحيه
قبل ان يستقل سياره خاصه ويتجول بنفسه في
شوارع المدينه
وكان رئيس روسي زارا في وقت سابق مقاطعه
روستوف جنوبيه روسيا حيث اجتمع بمركز
قياده العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا وقال
الكريم استمع الى تقارير من رئيس الاركان
العامه للقوات المسلحه الروسيه فاليري
جريما
وعدد من القاده العسكري
وكان الرئيس روسيا بزياره مفاجئه الى شبه
جزيره القرم في الذكرى التاسعه لضمها الى
روسيا وزاره بوتين الذي يعد مقرا رئيسيا
للاصول الروسي في البحر الاسود